all right boof okay cool hey everyone my
name is Sarah singer I am the executive
producer of mic mic is a digital news
company that's what we are for digital
is coming okay um why I'm here to tell
you guys today is this kind of crazy
kind of weird story that started on
August 12th 2009 that was just a few
weeks after I had graduated from college
I was getting myself so pumped up I was
getting ready to enter what was going to
be my first year as a special ed teacher
at a high school in the Bronx
five years later August 12 2017 I was in
Charlottesville Virginia with a small
film crew covering the unite the right
rally which going down there we thought
it was going to be this small little
thing turned out to be as I'm sure you
all know the alt Rights kind of
emergence into the mainstream at least
into the mainstream news cycle nina's
needless to say I'm really short I'm a
petite person and I'm a Jewish woman it
was a good fit it was the right story I
was welcome there um but those were just
about those were five years apart or
four-and-a-half years apart
um four years apart and oh my gosh what
a journey that was from being a special
ed teacher by bit my classroom was in
the basement to what is now running a
video team of mic we are in the 82nd
floor of the World Trade Center what a
journey so when I'm going to tell you
guys tonight are three lessons that I've
learned that actually I learned as a
teacher that have made me a better
professional out of made me a better
manager that I think about every single
day and this is about that evolution
number one and this is gonna sound
obvious but this is not this is this is
harder to do this is harder to do than
it is to say be flexible I studied
English in call
literature major love writing love
student journalism all the things with
words nonfiction fiction you name it
poetry so when I showed up the day
before the first day of school but the
day before my first year as a teacher I
got my class rosters at my class
schedule and I was teaching two classes
of earth science this was this was
special this was not perfect I actually
had never taken geology myself so this
was this was the moment this is the
moment of reckoning my mother in the
room can say there were lots of Tears
there was lots of panic there was lots
of not chillness but I was stuck with
this schedule that kids were coming in
in 12 hours what was I gonna do we got
it we got a roll we got to teach some
earth science so that was it like I was
teaching I so this was a high need
school and we're not gonna go into
educational policy right now but the
upshot of it is there was no curriculum
I was teaching us all to self-contained
classes which just means that 8 to 12
kids varying levels of needs everything
from learning disabled to
developmentally disabled we were
teaching regions level earth science
this was not an ideal situation for
anybody in the in the room but we we
rolled and my god did I become obsessed
with her science so that that experience
III finished that first year of teaching
thinking I could do I could do anything
I think you take an English major and
plop them into geology with students who
are special-needs students are amazing
people and just like amazing learners
just it's it's very hard sometimes to
break down material in that way we're
gonna make it work okay so the upshot of
it is be flexible how that had Mike
which used to be called policy Mike in
the four and a half years that I worked
at the company I was we were counting
this just at dinner right before this
event I had seven different seven
different jobs in the past four and a
half years and I'm sure the folks who
worked in startups or entrepreneurs or
have worked in very like quickly growing
companies can kind of like validate that
experience or it can live that and as
somebody who was a writer and an editor
of words who's transitioned into visual
journalism and video and self-taught
editor of motion graphics and of you
know just film in general oh my god we
just roll okay so that's number one be
flexible number two and this is where we
get a little Zen this is the idea of
embracing the whole you right and at
face value being a special ed teacher
and being an executive producer are two
completely different jobs but pull off
one layer and what you're doing is
telling stories and you're connecting
with audiences and the same skills that
enable somebody to be an effective
teacher breaking down new information
figuring out what's gonna make it
exciting to somebody relearning it
yourself knowing your audience an earth
science class for example is gonna look
different at the college level than it
is at the high school level and it is at
the middle school level those are the
exact same kind of skills or like
practices that we have in journalism
right the content is different but the
goal is the same break down stuff
happening out in the world figure out
who your audience is how can you best
translate what's happening in the world
to that audience and how can you can you
know debate them to action so rather
than looking at the differences between
these two jobs and saying oh my god I'm
gonna discount all that education stuff
and start and start from scratch as a
journalist and rather than kind of
putting up barriers around our different
careers whether they're at the same
company or at different companies using
those to your divergent paths or like
the unique experiences that make you you
and turning those into a collective kind
of like whole self and that whole self
that can only be you that's what makes
like I feel my co-workers that Mike's a
teacher Singh my last name is singer
you're saying teacher saying teachers
how to do video teachers had to do
whatever and like that's the realness
because I channel so much of that same
practice that I did in the classroom as
I do at my job now and like that's the
that's what makes me me and that's the
whole the whole you the homie okay great
number three here we are this is the now
this is the real Zen one this is the one
that I'm most excited about and this is
this is the idea of finding your daily
Zen and this is the hardest thing
especially as in startup world it is the
hardest thing to do because startups are
roller coasters
some days are the best thing some days
are the best days ever we're making it
we nailed it our company's the best no
problems like everything's perfect some
days are the worst oh my god it's all
ending we're done like this is the last
day I'm so sorry I'm so sorry everybody
we tried really hard I'm at peace with
it okay so the up the upshot of this is
I'm going out on a limb a limb here but
I think like I know this is something
that I worked really hard at as a woman
and I think many women in the room can
kind of empathize with like we hold on
to a lot of stuff like we're it's very
it's very kind of like intuitive to say
to know roast over something that
happened yesterday to just like not get
past something that a co-worker said
that you're so annoyed about like oh my
god he or she must hate me oh my god
like I really messed up three hours ago
about this thing or become so super like
preoccupied with something that could
happen three weeks from now if I do this
oh what's gonna happen then what what am
I gonna do like what's this person going
to say about me if I do this or whatever
whatever okay like neither of those
neither of those are happening now you
can't change what happened yesterday and
you have no idea what's going to happen
three weeks from now
so embracing the day and saying I'm in
charge of today and all that I could do
is create the waves I'm the captain of
my ship we used to say this in the
teaching in the teaching world as a
teacher you're the captain of your ship
but you also make the ocean right you
create the environment in which you're
really going to be kind of like
navigating and I think that that's
something that I think about all the
time every day leading this video team
and having gone through lots of
different
of policymic to Mike and all of that
stuff you really I mean it's it's up to
you how to best leverage there was ten
hours or eight hours or seven hours or
whatever your workday is and don't get
preoccupied cuz like that's so that's it
like the dailies I don't live your life
that's it bye
[Applause]
[Music]